oh Vanessa Bell your first year
sleepover Camp you're gonna love it
oh now don't forget day one through
three you're on your charcoal fast so
you don't need to worry about what
they're serving in the cafeteria but
after that you need to remember the
family model if it's not clean and green
it's just a dream and don't you even
think about it I've taken the liberty of
looking at the week's menu and I packed
all your favorite Provisions to make
sure that your stay is comfortable
gluten-free keto bread for french toast
day but just one slice because this has
to last you the month oh let it spun and
carry for hot dog roast you make sure to
tell all your bank mates that those
cancer sticks are going to age them in
five years we already spent too much on
Botox over here
oh I've got your favorite
the chocolate covered almond perfect for
when the top spots are making them
s'mores oh sugar on sugar on sugar all
damn kids are gonna come home with the
diabetes okay Vanessa Bell mommy loves
you but I'm already late for my
lymphatic drainage don't let us down